[Musik]
als luca und ich habe heute ein date
ich weiß niemand hatte damit gerechnet
wir spielen heute das game
ariana jubel bei ehrenberg
direkt an
[Musik]
asche
bodenkirchen jetzt bei der aryan drinnen
angekommen und wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit ein kompliment early stage
company oder gehört hat ich würde sagen
wir haben während der mutter mal an ich
stehe auf muttermale
jetzt kann ich wieder kippen oder
ich würde damit können sich einfach
normal alter die sie auf ihn vampir mit
ich würde sagen
seehofer mahnte tenue da draußen
wir haben wollte gern bescheid ich kürze
direkt
jetzt hat das ganze mal von vorne wieder
beiden wir fangen nicht an mit einem tag
sondern wir sagen etwas blutige blabla
sie lacht jetzt schon gern kürze labelle
weg in flake ich bin luca wir sagen
wieder dafür die menschen trinken
wollten mich wieder so ein bisschen und
jetzt würde ich aber sagen das gucken
sondern als hätten würde ich sagen die
wahl schere stein papier mit ihr weil
das ist das was man auf jeden fall bei
einem date machen sollte ich würde sagen
ich nehme einfach mal die hat aufgehört
dann will ich mal rossi hat derzeit ich
habe gewonnen
jetzt will ich sagen machen barbecue
[Musik]
beim letzten mal schon mal mit dem
erwartet die halter von jedem fakten
stern am himmel betiteln kann kann ich
nichts deswegen würde ich sagen wir wir
holen mal einfach den weinen jetzt ein
bisschen wein trinkt auch wieder auf das
hier vorne alter zwischen alien klinik
wir warten mal auf die vertreten wir ein
bisschen zu ihr kompliment
that work out in the thinker nein
wenn ich ihr haus jetzt loben dann würde
ich sagen apple etwa mit
dann würde ich sagen wann gehen wir
jetzt mal vom living room
dann machen wir können ihre brüste
anfassen tiere einfach mal sagen wir
denken für ein bisschen morgige spiel
mit romantisches wir deppen and kippen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt also an dieser stelle
hier gerade im video bei dapd nrd
dem beugt man gehen wir berühren ihre
brüste ich denke mal auch weiter das
irgendwie kommt uns aber schon sehr nahe
weiter geht es mit schenk mir wird man
bis zum rockigen enden wir hier richtig
ab
rocking blabla jetzt gehen wir mal
woanders hin wird die waage bringt mir
wieder ein bisschen feiern das lieber
ein bisschen in stimmung aufgeheitert
kommt jetzt würde ich sagen was ihre ich
ihre schuld an
hier gefällt abtransport ein peeling
relax sie gehen jetzt einfach mal
woanders hin würde ich sagen und lobt
dann würde ich sagen wir gehen einfach
mal auf den driver's fahren einfach mal
wir holen erst mal ein bisschen geld
damit wir quasi noch ein bisschen was im
tank haben wir füllen einfach mal den
tank auf die macht ein foto von mir wo
die braut dahinter wenn ihr auch ganz
schön scharf wir haben jetzt entweder
die möglichkeit in die berge zu fahren
oder downtown ich würde einfach mal
sagen wir fahren in die berge
jetzt gehen wir einfach mal auf die
mountain fahren weiter hoch ob haye
sitzt das schon seit ob sie etwas
erwarten würde ich denke einfach mal auf
weiter letztere den lockeren wie machten
habe bilder dass wir die komplette stadt
vor
mädel diese fotografiert für mich die
ganze zeit ich mache jetzt gerade bilder
von ihr und dem bild von ihr gemacht
habt ihr model sage ich einfach mal
blabla
komac out in the cars that make money
fair trial modeling post ich würde sagen
sie versucht es mal ein bisschen mit dem
modeln jetzt und jetzt würde ich mal
sagen art körper neben sexy ab alles
okay meine damen und herren ich habe
angst dass dieses video wieder von
youtube oder richtung gedrängt wird +18
ihr das ganze hier ja schon zwei dreimal
hochgeladen und die erst einmal habe ich
kläglich versagt aber beim letzten mal
natürlichkeit ausgezogen und alle und
ich habe eigentlich alles zensiert und
youtube ab 18 freigegeben
deswegen werden gleich gegen etwas
kommen sollte wohl nackte haut gezeigt
werde ich einfach komplett den
kompletten screen zensieren nur schon
mal soll es keine vorwarnung
sie steht jetzt lieber mit dem model
inzwischen wie kann er gleich sagen ja
perfekt oder kürten auf big audio passt
dass sie ihren po ausstrecken soll ich
weiß ihr deckt alle zuhause hey luca
drückt nochmal da drauf aber leute ich
bin ich mir das wirklich nicht plötzlich
jetzt okay so drauf norden ziehen ab
sofort mit let go back
wir sind wieder bei ich wollte er das
andere drücke ich hatte nur für den job
da drauf gedrückt aber jetzt habe ich
alles verkackt wir kürzen sie einfach
mal zum abschluss bleiben wie winkt uns
zu und wir haben verkackt aber ich würde
sagen ein drittes mal geht noch wie lädt
und wieder zu sich ein wir gehen rein
wir sagen einfach mal irgendwas luftige
nicht mal dann sage ich aber direkt
detention ist macht dieser wirklich
genauso wie vorhin gemacht habe
wir haben nie wieder das gleiche bild
die fbp ich verloren und würde ich sagen
dass ich jetzt mal wieder weinhohle wir
trinken jetzt eine trinken wieder waren
privat noch die fixierten bisschen beim
spot ein kompliment für ihr zählt jetzt
ein bisschen gedreht er trinkt ein
bisschen weinen dann würde ich sagen go
tour die kitchen vor die sehr
die lebkuchen wir spielen spindler und
wir machen
3 ich dir wieder einen driver zu
erfahren ich wurde noch ein bisschen
bilder von mir gefahren wieder nach oben
in die mountain sind jetzt oben
angekommen sie macht wieder ein bild von
mir jetzt würde ich sagen dass ich jetzt
wieder ein bild von ihr machen hier
genau ich könnte morgen wieder über
etwas verfeinert so toll aus die der
mich sozusagen arte treiben modeling
kurz danach wieder modeling porsche
gegolten sagt ex jako vision jetzt kommt
die wieder hier mit an und jetzt mit
einem kumpel vorhin waren wo ich darauf
gerückt habe ein ausblick auf die optik
hat wie jetzt sogar gesagt watch it hot
whirlpool ist also mit wandte sich
[Musik]
ich glaube hier muss ich noch nicht
zensieren jetzt jetzt musste ich gerade
wirklich wenn wir meine damen und herren
sie zeigt mir hier gerade einen apple
also dieses spiel alter haben etwa die
auswahlmöglichkeit nein
julia das ist für deinen alltag jetzt
einfach mal vorbei damit weiter jetzt
hat die zensierung glaube ich weg weil
ihr zeigt er nicht mehr hier ist alles
perfekt wieder für die youtube
richtlinien ich kann entweder sagen
gebaut worden network holding führt also
ich hab mich darüber mit meinem netzwerk
unterhalten und so was muss ich
definitiv nicht entgehen weil das werk
war sie genauso wie wenn wird zensiert
werden aber wie schlechte gerade hater
und pixelnet wait to get my pants of das
heißt ihre hosen noch ausziehen
[Musik]
wir haben wieder ein stück bekommen
die paar tage hier sogar nur mit einer
wild kein bock auf die zu kürzen sie
bringen wieder und bahn
wir haben wieder mal verschiffen
das was jetzt aber auf meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn ihr noch mal teil davon reden
wollte das nicht vielleicht noch mal
probieren dass wir vielleicht bis zum
allerletzten ende vom spiel kommt
nachbar leiter und bei 5 ist cool eli
geil geil
ja ich weiß aber irgendwann brauchen
jetzt in der endart wenn euch das video
bezahlt hat die gewagten darauf
hochladen könnt ihr nur als kanal
abonnieren auf dem naiven kostenlos eine
gewerkschaft eingeblendet sondern job
oder ja genau
ok anderen video eingeblendet
wenig zu tun
ich glaube ganz okay